what's up gamers it's gaming week say it
with me gaming week today we're playing
more minecraft that's right everybody
I finished my house it's got a glass
ceiling now yeah that's awesome Felix I
know and watch this all my planes have
grown so much what do you think of that
cheap I've also look at the flowers okay
how cute is my house comment right now
and you can win an Xbox so I made this
stable because today bros we have lots
of things to do and one of the first
things we're gonna do is we're gonna
ride the goddamn horses oh wait sorry I
need to goddamn it I need to use my home
to get this weed out that's right
because we're gonna use the wheat to
learn out the horses I think that's how
it works I don't know listen I know more
about Minecraft than you do so they
didn't even talk to me all right
does your house a farm look epic like
this what is this bait throat what what
is this is this melon what is this
pumpkin this is the thing with myung
truck craft do you think you're gonna do
one thing and then you get distracted
with a million other things I don't have
to do this I just feel like I have to do
this now look how fast I am though I'm
the fastest planter farmer in the world
this is what can you stop distracting me
this is why people waited for me to play
Minecraft all these years just to see me
plant seeds like no other planter before
have we got more melon what the did you
come from what kind of recipe can I make
okay gamers so we haven't wheat we have
these horses they've been here since
episode 1 throwback to episode 1 of
gamer week I'm gonna ride this horse and
you take it that's right take it take it
how much do they need how much wheat
do you like that does he trust me now
are we friends now are we cool now how
much weed would you like that's all my
wheat supply thanks yeah I got two hey
did I tell you that leave I wanna ride
you go go away uh why wear it wear it
wear it wear it y'all got your again for
fun your again do not have her with me I
have named you you should be happy y'all
get what do you want maybe Apple maybe
he wants Apple
I have golden apple maybe I should feed
him then how to ride for spine crash hey
guys what's up so today we will do the -
just tell me I don't need to listen to
you first you must tame the horse each
horse must be tame to tame horse do you
want to waste my time anymore you must
use your hand to tame horse you will
tame horse by repeatedly trying to mount
the horse and getting back done
what so I just have to harass the wars
in two sitting with me I can do they may
your again oh I think I tamed the waters
I did it
minecraft how do I jump it's better
sailor on this [ __ ]
you're again we're going so fast oh god
you're installing okay
Jurgen is too fat for my stable Jurgen
bleeds come on go in and all the time
god you're useless Jurgen all right do
you fit in my house get up okay we're
cool right good boy here let's give him
an amp a year again you like some apple
you're a kid you gotta get for fun
no you want that bull you want that for
trying to eat the ah alright fine
well I still need your again to stay so
I'm going to make Jurgen cuddles new
house alright this is where you live
that's definitely what I wanted to do
alright you live here you again don't
look at me like that I have other things
to do today alright I have a bucket list
full of things
isn't that right sheep you're useless
pathetic I'll see you at night at dinner
we have uragan next up is we're gonna
make a portal and we're gonna enter the
thing but first we need to make pocket
and to make bucket I know this because
I'm actually a veteran at Minecraft a
lot of people don't know this I know how
to make buckets all right what is that
no get I can't say that bad word next up
we fill the bucket what up Jurgen you
filled the bucket with water as such
there we go we filled it with bucket
what'd I just say
and next up we just have to dig straight
down Bruce I know it's crazy
wait where was the mine I had a mind
somewhere oh yes of course here it is
shut your mouth you have no friends
the audacity of some people jab bloody
feet on [ __ ] god damn it oh why did they
do that I thought it would stop getting
scared after a walk you distracted me
and look what happened
need to : ow damn I could start a coal
mining business look how much there is
you shut up alright so we need to go to
lava clearly very scary thing I need to
make sure this is late otherwise enemies
spawn what is this this is all I built
all right we're gonna have to dig down
there and hopefully we'll find lava
sooner than later
oh okay here's my old right I just gonna
make sure I find my way out of this kid
mains
alright where's the lava oh my god gross
that's very scary sound what is that
sound
hello game sound very scary where is my
lava I know a lot of people have a
stigma against digging straight down but
you do understand that you need balls to
play Minecraft oh I hear the lava what
would take you years of practice and
research takes me only a couple of
seconds because I got ball oh yeah oh
yeah we're getting close
mr. lava oh yeah Rickman's oh yeah oh
yeah found you found you mr. lava Wow
look at that like a look eh eh eh now we
take a bucket water and we pour it in
the lava how do I do that
goddammit okay cool I found water and I
can just walk button what it never works
grab it grab it grab the water okay I
got it so I can do weird okay so this is
how you do it you just pour it here whoa
we just made whatever this is I don't
remember if you could actually mine
these back in the day but we need these
apparently they take forever to farm so
this should be a big bottom did I get it
though no I didn't get it why not
ice bucket challenge come on doing Felix
I love minecraft bunch of nerds who play
minecraft dude I'm breaking my eye
diamond mine path for this it's getting
totally ruined
[Music]
[Music]
in the midst of my panic you may have
thought that I was pure panic but I
actually managed to go to the surface so
I think I didn't actually lose my items
pray to knotch and gaben's baby Oh God
because if my stuff falls in the lava
it's over
okay guys smash like on this video if
you think it's over
you guys warned me for that yeah thank
God alright maybe some stuff fell in no
we're fine we're fine we're completely
fine my legs are here Oh God thank gaben
that was a true gamer moment in the
midst of that panic I persevered look I
have a diamond helmet now and I almost
lost it this is why you need to be
careful when you play video game you
know so I have to be close to pick it up
then I also have to be far away that way
did I get it nope I didn't get it stupid
love a stinky lava you stink too lava I
don't lie about you eat my ants what I
can grab lava in a bucket that seems
very unsafe so far I have 0 death on
this server so I would really like to
keep it that way I haven't died yet
so alright so 7 how many do I need 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 2010
I have 12 I think that's enough all
right we're going back epic epic epic
epic epic epic epic smash like on this
video a few things epic and you could
give me an Xbox
alright gamers that was success what the
hell this is my old mineshaft oh my god
that goes to my house oh there's a
Minecraft house
Jerr again you're still there all right
there you go
okay gamers what was I doing ah yes we
were building an epic portal to the
nether realm should we build here where
should I build it sure let's do it here
I never done this that was not like back
when I was a gamer like I've never been
to the nether realm should I be scared
so how many blocks do I need again does
that work okay so why does he not open
excuse me I thought this was all I had
to do answer me sheep how to open up the
portal flint and steel what where do I
get Flint from I was impossible no god
damn it hey god damn man
maybe needs to be Knight how do I fight
Flint from gravel alright I guess back
to the mind we go boys how does gravel
look like is this crapple die alright
what the Frick is a die alright like
what is what is it stay alright I need
gavel so ready for an epic adventure but
I need to get happen like what is gravel
I've never seen it and I played for
hours it's not just rolling me like when
you find coal it's so obvious gold oh
yeah alright could this be what is that
what was that gravel Gavin weed I know a
grapple where's the flame
where's the goddamn Flint do I need to
farm it with something else
continue to dig up gravel until Flint
appears so far no luck buddy
how rare is Flint dude yes I saw it we
have one voice mission accomplished
god damn travel you son yeah alright now
we just gotta find our way back and then
we're good see time to head back home
boys another mission accomplished
is it raining what it rains in Minecraft
uragan it's always I have to build the
roof for you sorry your again look at
that that's so cozy that's amazing so
whatever what do I do with the Flint I
need an iron ingot all right I think I
can scrap a lot one of those oh my god
cool no I don't want it I don't want it
I damn it I made nuggets okay so it's
raining but I think that that fits the
aesthetic of what we're doing because
we're going through the nether portal
bros alright ah ba ba ba ba ya ba ba ba
ba alright you're again let's go on our
biggest adventure we have ever gone to
I'll bring a carrot in case we get
hungry maybe I should bring some food
actually okay
Oh any my shield okay yaar again it's
gaming time
kidding me Jurgen can't enter
what kind of discrimination it's this
we're gonna ride out in the dawn like
they did in Lord of the Rings what the
hell your again wait there alright I'm
just gonna check if that's the case
maybe my stairs messed it up or
something no ah your again wait for me
wait for me on the other side we're
entering the nether realm what's
happening what's happening up freakin
out what's the farting whoa whoa whoa
minecraft this is okay alright farm we
need this we need this we need this
alright
remember the rules you can't hurt they
can't hurt us in the holes I'll dude I'm
getting epic XP from being in here this
is very epic but we must be careful and
it's not forget hell isn't real they
said but they have not seen them nether
ran for real why is this game so scary
dude what can you find here I actually I
don't know wait wait where's my poor
love I already lost it
there you are oh god it's such a
terrible decision oh my god there's so
much love I did Oh Carol dude Oh what is
that that's got to be precious material
they may have strength and courage but I
have a mining skills what am I looking
for mushrooms am I supposed to kill you
guys
I don't want that I want to be friends
with them look at their houses on fire
of course they're gonna be angry look at
them he just wants to jump all day I get
it I'm the same what happens if you
don't find your way back hold like God
what happens it's too uragan let's be
friends okay let's be friends okay hey
hey hey hey not for all right all right
it's gonna be like that it's got to be
like that I'm not the one making the
rules I'm 9 by wish you'd all be dead
it's like know where it goes No oh god
this is it it's this it I don't have
water I don't have water I'm burning up
I'm burning up I can't die Jorgen is
waiting for me the lava
stop we're gonna make a picture your
again I gotta make it back though me
[Music]
oh my god that was Gray's it's still
raining are you kidding me alright I've
learned my lesson
I'm not going anywhere without water
again okay bro so in the next episode
we're gonna go fishing smash like if you
want more epic Minecraft Let's Plays and
I'll see you brows next time what you
never played tuber simulator you know
it's fun right I'm not supposed to give
my opinion but give it a try and then
you can tell me if it's good or not
convinced yet okay I'll cut you a deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]